Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Beatrice Chiamenti
Quando sentite la parola "microbi",
a che cosa pensate?
La maggior parte delle persone
pensa a sporcizia, infezioni, malattie.
Ma in realtà i microbi,
o microrganismi, per noi pericolosi,
sono solo una piccola percentuale.
La maggior parte di essi
ha un ruolo fondamentale
per la vita di ognuno di noi
e per quella dell'intero pianeta.
I microbi prendono il loro nome
dal fatto che sono piccolissimi,
delle dimensioni del micron:
il micron è la millesima parte
del millimetro.
Quindi essi sono invisibili
ad occhio nudo.
Ma compensano le loro
ridotte dimensioni con il numero,
infatti sono gli organismi
più abbondanti sulla Terra.
Pensate che un grammo di suolo
ne contiene circa un miliardo.
Essi sono fondamentali per tutti
i cicli bio-geo-chimici:
per esempio,
un particolare tipo di batterio
conosciuto come cianobatterio,
per primo, circa 3 miliardi
e mezzo di anni fa,
utilizzò l'idrogeno dell'acqua
liberando ossigeno,
inventando così la fotosintesi
e permettendo lo sviluppo
della vita sulla Terra
così come la conosciamo noi oggi.
Seppure inconsapevolmente,
l'uomo li ha da sempre utilizzati
per la fermentazione di cibi e bevande.
E oggi i microbi trovano
largo impiego in diversi settori,
dall'industria farmaceutica
alla bonifica di siti inquinati.
Per esempio,
vi ricordate il disastro ambientale
successo nel Golfo del Messico nel 2010?
Fu il disastro ambientale peggiore
nella storia degli Stati Uniti:
circa nove litri di greggio,
al secondo, per tre mesi,
fuoriuscirono dalla piattaforma
petrolifera Deep Water Horizon,
che vedete alle mie spalle.
La marea nera era impressionante:
in tutto furono riversati in mare dai tre
ai cinque milioni di barili di petrolio.
Ad eccezione di circa 800.000 barili,
che furono aspirati o dati
alle fiamme in roghi controllati,
gran parte del petrolio
fu letteralmente digerito
da microrganismi naturalmente presenti
nelle acque dell'Oceano.
E uno di questi appartiene
al genere Alcanivorax,
che grazie a un processo
chiamato bioremediation
ha contribuito a bonificare
il Golfo del Messico.
Bene: i batteri,
e i microrganismi in generale,
così come sono in grado
di rimuovere gli inquinanti
dall'acqua, o anche dal suolo,
allo stesso modo possono essere utili
per rimuovere sostanze indesiderate
da superfici che noi vogliamo
preservare nel tempo.
È questo il caso di un altro
batterio molto interessante,
Disulfovibrio Vulgaris.
Questo batterio è un solfato-riduttore,
cioè utilizza i composti
dello zolfo per respirare,
così come noi utilizziamo l'ossigeno.
Grazie a questa sua capacità metabolica,
Disulfovibrio può essere utilizzato
per rimuovere, da statue e monumenti,
le croste nere solfatiche
che si formano a causa dello smog.
Infatti Disulfovibrio,
applicato sulla alterazione,
è in grado di aggredire
la componente solfatica dalla crosta,
destrutturandola
e permettendo al restauratore
una facile rimozione,
senza l'utilizzo di solventi chimici,
o senza le sabbiature,
nel pieno rispetto dell'opera,
dell'operatore e dell'ambiente.
In questa immagine
potete vedere una statua,
prima e dopo il restauro
con Disulfovibrio vulgaris.
Ormai è stranota l'importanza
che hanno i microbi che albergano
l'intestino umano,
e quello di tanti animali
- di tutti gli animali!
Ma forse non sapete
quanto siano importanti
i microbi che vivono all'interno
delle radici delle piante.
Un batterio interessante
è un particolare tipo di bacillus,
che vive all'interno delle radici
di piante orticole.
Questa batterio stimola lo sviluppo
dell'apparato radicale delle piante.
E quindi, radici più robuste
permettono alla pianta di gestire meglio
la risorsa idrica nel suolo,
anche in condizioni di siccità.
Alle mie spalle potete vedere
le radici di una pianta di peperone
trattate con questo bacillus:
di fianco, invece, le radici
di una pianta non trattata.
Quest'altra immagine, invece,
fa riferimento alle parti aeree
delle stesse piante,
una trattata con bacillus e l'altra no.
Infine, vi vorrei parlare di alcuni
batteri che in assenza di ossigeno,
secondo un processo
chiamato digestione anaerobica,
sono in grado, a partire
da sostanza organica
come per esempio gli scarti
dell'agro-industria,
di produrre biogas (CO2 e metano)
e quindi di generare energia.
In questo video vedrete
un digestore anaerobico in miniatura
che grazie alla materia organica
in esso presente,
e grazie all'attività dei microrganismi,
riesce a produrre biogas,
che viene conservato nel palloncino.
Il metano, presente nel biogas,
vicino a un innesco libera poi energia,
rappresentata dalla fiamma.
Bene.
I batteri, però,
non fanno solo cose utili:
fanno anche cose belle!
Per esempio, la scritta
sulla mia maglietta "I love microbes"
- e in questa immagine vedete
una fase della preparazione -
è stata realizzata con due batteri:
un batterio viola, isolato - pensate -
dalla pelle di una salamandra;
mentre il cuore rosso è stato realizzato
con un batterio tipico del suolo.
Che i batteri,
e i microrganismi in generale,
possano essere utilizzati
per dare un servizio all'uomo
è un concetto che si
sintetizza in tre parole:
Gestione della Risorsa Microbica.
Questo concetto pone le sue basi
su un concetto ancora più famoso,
che è quello della gestione
della risorsa umana.
Così come nelle aziende
il personale viene gestito,
guidato in base alle proprie
skills e competenze,
al fine di dare un vantaggio all'azienda,
allo stesso modo i microrganismi
possono essere gestiti
al fine di indurre un effetto positivo
là dove essi vengono applicati,
sia esso l'acqua, la superficie
di un monumento,
o l'interno del nostro corpo.
Volete sperimentare voi,
in prima persona,
il concetto che ho appena detto?
Bene.
Se siete amanti dello yogurt,
magari anche di quegli yogurt probiotici,
vi svelo il segreto,
qualora non lo sappiate già,
per avere sempre pronto a disposizione
il vostro probiotico preferito.
Allora, prendete una confezione
del vostro probiotico preferito,
un litro di latte,
una pentola dalla capienza
di un litro, col coperchio,
e una sciarpa di lana.
Quindi mettete il latte nella pentola,
e riscaldatelo alla temperatura
di circa 37-40 gradi.
Ve ne accorgete
che è la temperatura giusta
perché immergendo il dito
sentirete il latte un po' più caldo
della vostra temperatura corporea.
Ovviamente lavatevi le mani,
prima di fare questa operazione,
onde evitare che nel latte si sviluppino,
prolifichino batteri indesiderati.
Comunque, raggiunta
la temperatura giusta,
versate lo yogurt nel latte, mescolate,
mettete il coperchio e avvolgete il tutto
con la sciarpa di lana,
e aspettate un'intera notte.
I batteri lattici che erano presenti
nello yogurt di partenza,
durante la notte si moltiplicheranno
e grazie a processi fermentativi
tutto il latte diventerà yogurt.
Mettendo bene da parte un bicchierino,
potrete ripetere
questa operazione all'infinito,
e avere sempre a disposizione
il vostro probiotico
senza poi dover smaltire
la plastica della confezione,
e con un risparmio anche sulla spesa.
I batteri fanno tante cose, vero?
E stasera ne abbiamo visto solo alcune:
come sono in grado
di bonificare siti inquinati;
di restaurare monumenti;
produrre energia;
colorare i tessuti; fare lo yogurt;
far crescere le piante
in condizioni di siccità.
Quindi, la prossima volta
che sentite la parola "microbi",
io spero che non vi vengano in mente
solamente pestilenze e malattie,
ma tutte quelle applicazioni
che fanno dei microbi
i nostri migliori alleati
nella ricerca di soluzioni efficaci
e sostenibili ai problemi ambientali.
La risorsa microbica è una risorsa
potenzialmente illimitata,
e se adeguatamente gestita
può essere molto utile
per mitigare gli effetti dell'impatto
antropico sul nostro pianeta.
(Applausi)